[Musique]
à une certaine époque nous aurions pu
l'apercevoir entre les arbres c'est ici
au bord de ce lac que les femelles
viennent mettre bas pourtant où est il
ce caribou ou sont-ils les survivants sa
harde message d'une l'homme voulait
chemin qu'est ce que vous faites pour
mieux dès maintenant c'est au tour des
humains de les déposer
jean cormier n'ose plus penser à toutes
les fois où il a sillonné 606 au sud de
val d'or c'était l'époque où ils osaient
encore rêver voit ici on s'était
vraiment halal un flot de l'espoir
passez donc on a commencé à pouvoir
mettre les femelles en gestation pour
qu'il y ait eu leur petit l'enfant une
façon sécuritaire pour conclure après
celle des mets ta liberté dans leur
nouvelle maison
ceci représente espère ainsi que
l'espoir c'était d'assurer la survie
d'un tout petit groupe les quelques
rescapés d'un grand troupeau qui a
longtemps peuple et les forêts de
l'abitibi la question ils ne tireront
d'une possible opa est présent dans ces
noms pour bien saisir la nature du débat
nous sommes allés à la recherche de ces
caribou un animal fragile qui vit caché
sous les conifères
[Musique]
quelques minutes de vol suffisent
partout leur territoire est perturbé par
les coupes forestières passé hachuré par
les chemins de coupe de véritables
autoroutes pour les prédateurs loups les
ours aussi qui s'attaque aux enfants
ajouter les chalets
quand chasse et vtt le caribou ici n'a
pas beaucoup de chance
c'est un peu le canari dans la mine
donc le fait qu'il décline cette vitesse
là et qu'il faut peut-être c'est time
prochainement
c'est un signal comme quoi notre
aménagement forestier prendre un emploi
durable et soutenable dans la région
martin yves saint laurent est un des
grands experts du caribou forestier au
québec
il rappelle que le caribou est protégé
par la loi fédérale sur les espèces en
péril
le problème c'est que le sauver ne
serait pas simple donc on doit restaurer
les conditions d'habitat favorable au
caribou et où entre temps diminué les
densités de prédateurs au maximum pour
être capable d'amener un habitant
wasquehal individus vont pouvoir
survivre
le temps que la matrice forestière
redeviennent favorables et ça ça demande
du temps du temps et aucune garantie de
succès même l'écologiste le plus connu
des beats ebe de concède ce qu'on est
sûr si on continue comme ça dans
l'environnement de ce 15ème lilian ne
put se sait c'est définitif c'est pas
sûr qu'on va le sauver mais en tant que
société est ce qu on a droit de dire
parce qu'on pense qui a reçu une chanson
l'apprendre prochain il ne reste plus
que 18 caribou à val d'or voilà pourquoi
cet enclos aujourd'hui abandonnés
étaient si porteur d'espoir celui de
donner un coup de pouce ou femelle et à
leurs fins le biologiste marcel paris
était au coeur de cette opération donc
chaque fois contre une population ou une
espèce on gruge beaucoup sur la capitale
capitale vivant si on veut et dans ce
sens là c'est important de faire ce qui
est passé mark up pour maintenir ou
sauver des populations en situation
précaire or après deux ans malgré la
survie défend une femelle est morte
québec abandonné le projet trop risqué
sa peau était parfait mais il reste le
terrible tout bonnement jamais arrêté
mais tout aussi sur un produit malgré
toutes les épreuves furent là c'est as
près de pau et des données aucun espoir
et vertu de ce point
ainsi nicole à québec les mystères de la
forêt de la foule et des parcs a tranché
une étude évalue qu'il en coûterait 76
millions $ sur cinq ans tente et 187
emplois pour sauver l'art de val d'or
c'est trop et il faudrait pratiquement
sur saint quentin à l'échelle de deux
mille cent cinquante kilomètres carrés
dans le fond arrêter toute forme
d'intervention pour permettre sur une
période de 50 ans la revenu dans le fond
d'un habitat favorable aux quais les
goula de santé dans une région où chaque
kilomètre carré un potentiel économique
pour la foresterie ou l'industrie
minière les 18 caribou ne font pas le
poids
est-ce qu'on arrête la divine et humaine
parlez-en au maire de val-d'or qui
rappelle que le caribou a tout de même
droit à une aire protégée
ça peut paraître abstrait 435 kilomètres
carrés ça correspond à quoi à 10% presse
et la grandeur de l'île de montréal
sur l'est de montréal ya un million huit
cent soixante mille être humain est ici
il ya 18 caribou qui ont de la misère à
fonctionner donc aujourd'hui on est dans
un dossier où est ce qu'on dit mais ont
laissé la harde certaine sur place le
potentiel aurifère le potentiel
forestier est trop important dans la
région
il faut dire que l'exemple vient de haut
comme jobs pour les galibots sur toutes
les tribunes depuis la dernière campagne
le premier ministre couillard a martelé
même message oui oui la sauvegarde du
caribou forestier est important mais pas
question de sacrifier des jobs en forêt
ou en usine pour sa pour l'ex biologiste
responsable des caribous de val d'or dès
l'arrivée au pouvoir des libéraux
le signal était clair mais vous aide il
faut des simples radioamateurs on
n'avait même pas les ressources fallait
les en tout cas rater d'autres régions
qui en a le plus besoin c'est pas
décourageant
c'était décourageant québec promet
maintenant de concentrer ses efforts sur
les 8000 autres caribou forestier dans
la province
on s'est probablement réveiller trop
tard notre copain c'est l'échec
on a des bonnes indications ce qu'il
faut pas faire avec val d'or puis ce
qu'on est en train de deux je vous
dirais de mettre en branle pour
l'ensemble des populations et mais les
alliés du caribou de val d'or ne perdent
pas espoir il compte sur ottawa pour que
le fédéral intervienne en vertu de la
loi sur les espèces en péril
comme lorsqu'il a freiné un projet
immobilier à la prairie en 2016 pour
protéger la rainette faux grillon le
caribou des denrées un point de dominos
tout faire tout tomber le risque est
vulnérable
puis ces sonates et régla c'est pour ça
qu'on est résilient
c'est pour ça qu'on est là pour dire non
c'est assez
[Musique]
malgré tout le débat qu'il soulève notre
caribou demeure bien discret jamais il
n'est sorti de son petit oasis
d'épinettes seul dans sa forêt si
convoité menacé d'extinction le caribou
de val d'or ne prend plus aucun risque
[Musique]